[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture et nous avons une
invitée exceptionnelle type delphine
horvilleur pour son son livre que nous
avons adoré vivre avec nos morts n'est
ce pas me qualifier
et oui tout à fait bonjour et merci
beaucoup delphine horvilleur d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
alors vous êtes une des rares femmes
rabbins en france vous êtes également
écrivain vos livres place la
transmission l'identité au coeur de vos
questionnements et c'est ce qu'on disait
avec patrice notre bonheur à vous lire a
à chaque fois vient sans doute de votre
talent à montrer comment les récits les
textes religieux les mythologies enfin
bref les livres et bien nous aide à
comprendre le monde et cette approche
que vous avez tissé au fil de vos écrits
eh bien nous la retrouvons dans votre
dernier livre vivre avec nos morts qui
est numéro un des ventes d'essais alors
delphine horvilleur vous écrivez que le
métier qui se rapproche le plus de rabat
c'est celui de conteur
qu'est ce que c'est un conteur est ce
que c'est celui qui nous raconte des
histoires ou alors qu'il nous fait
toucher là la vérité au plus près avec
depuis des années quand les gens me
demandent ce qu'est mon métier savin
souvent les gens savent pas exactement
ce que c'est qu'un rabbin ce concert
fait un rabbin c'est pour toi un
enseignant et plus le temps passe plus
j'ai l'impression ce qui se rapproche le
plus de de l'engagement à binic c'est
effectivement un métier de conteur de
dire s'efforcer de raconter des
histoires qui ont déjà été racontée mais
les raconter dans un contexte nouveau et
faire qu'elle gagne une pertinence
particulière je crois qu'on sait où on
est nombreux à s'être rendu compte au
coeur de cette crise à quel point ce
dont on avait besoin par dessus tout
c'était de deux récits d'histoires qui
nous relient en fait on est
désespérément en quête de liens quand on
se sent tellement vrai tellement
interdépendants et c'est vrai que moi je
m'efforce dans mon métier de rabbins
quand j'accompagne les jugements de
penser la force des histoires la façon
dont ces histoires ancestrales peuvent
résonner de presque complètement inédite
pour eux et les aider à se relever
parfois à rester debout au coeur des
grands orages que
malheureusement traverse dans
l'existence je dois rentrer alors un peu
dans les eaux ce tableau qui qui qui
composent votre livre mais nathalie
lisez vous êtes voilà le livre est en
tête des ventes et en même temps vous
montrer très bien comment on a mis de
plus en plus de sociétés la mort à
distance et et pourtant quand quelqu'un
abonde aborde frontalement ce sujet
comme vous comme vous le faites et bien
les gens se précipitent alors qu'est ce
que ce succès à votre sens nous dit de
notre rapport à la mort d'abord je dois
dire je suis assez bouleversé par
l'accueil qui est réservé aux livres je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils aient eu à
ce qui déclenche effectivement ça je
reçois chaque jour des dizaines et des
dizaines de lettres de gens qui
réagissent à la lecture du livre et qui
viennent me raconter leur propre
histoire plutôt à compte à quel point
ils n'ont eu personne à qui en comptait
cette histoire en fait on vit dans une
société où souvent les gens gardent leur
deuil et leur douleur et ses moments
sacrés il n'y a pas d'autres mots le
deuil c'est un moment sacré au sens où
c'est un temps hors du temps mais dans
nos sociétés on n'a personne à qu'il
racontait je pense que près société plus
traditionnelle il ya des gens qui
remplissent un peu cette fonction il ya
une conscience un peu plus naturelle du
lien entre les mondes entre ceux qui ne
sont plus ceux qui se sont et ce qu'ils
seront un jour et dans nos sociétés très
rationaliste moderne techniques
technologiques
on a l'impression qu'il ya plus d espace
pour cette parole cheikh certains vont
le trouver tout est dans la psychanalyse
d'autres dans la littérature mais mais
en fait on a l'impression qu'il n'ya pas
vraiment une parole politique collectif
permet de porter de porter cela et donc
il ya un manque très fort et je pense
que le succès du livre à avoir avec star
avec la conscience d'un d'un manque que
mauvaise bolivien en vie
et l'un des premiers tableaux pour
l'enterrement d'elisa khayat
psychanalyste et chroniqueur à charlie
hebdo où elle a été assassinée lors de
l'attentât de 2015 sa famille semble
rassurer vous soyez entre guillemets
ramin laïque c'est drôle c'est un
oxymore
alors votre essai c'est vrai qu'il met
en scène des protagonistes qui sont pas
toujours religieux parfois même à
s'éloigner de la religion mais alors
justement ce rapprochement entre ces
deux mots rabbin et là il peut étonner
est-ce qu'il ya chez vous aussi alors
une volonté peut-être de dire que
croyance et laïcité ne sont pas
antinomiques
oui en fait vrai comment ce cet attribut
m'a été donné dans la star dès le haka
yatma présenter à sa famille en disant
que j'étais khabar laïque j'ai sursauté
moi aussi à cette expression mais je
comprenais exactement ce qu'elle voulait
dire par là c'est à dire que je crois
que la laïcité et quel que soit ce à
quoi on croit ou on ne croit pas nous
permet quand même de faire dans la de la
place dans nos vies pour des récits
ancestraux moi j'ai l'impression que
voilà comme rabat quand j'officie j'ai
pas besoin de me poser la question de ce
en quoi mon interlocuteur croix ou ne
crois pas alors c'est peut-être une
spécificité un peu quand même de la
pensée juive parce que le judaïsme est
une tradition religieuse qui n'est pas
temps contre et pour la croyance que
d'autres traditions religieuses
la tradition oui il ya beaucoup de gens
qui me disent juifs frontalement à théo
mais pour qu'ils leur judaïsme est
affaire de deux cultures parfois une
certaine façon de raconter des histoires
d'appartenir à un peuple d'avoir une
relation particulière à son histoire et
tout ça les seins et pas simplement une
affaire de croyance ou de dogme donc ça
qui m'importe pour moi de pouvoir parler
beaucoup plus largement que cela j'ai la
conviction que nos traditions
religieuses ou un langage particulier
qui leur permet de parler l'universel et
aujourd'hui peut-être plus que jamais au
coeur de cruz c'est souvent comme ça on
a besoin que des langages particulier
nous raconte l'universel allez y ait des
pages très forte je pense notamment
celles où vous parlez de simone veil et
de marceline loridan-ivens vous devez
vous rappeler comment elle s'appelait la
fille de birnau est vrai que c'est un
certain
c'est terrible comme comme comme
appellation est si bonne nouvelle donc
vous dit que c'est peut-être le fait la
figure humaine de la fait d'ailleurs est
vrai vous dites et je trouve cette
phrase très forte enfants on à médéa
elle cette idée un peu galvaudé vous
dites de résilience et c'est vrai
qu'elle est un peu galvaudé sept livres
résidence oui parce qu'en fait on
utilise tellement on la met à toutes les
sauces ou terme utilisé par tout ce qui
est que il a perdu un peu de sa
résonance ou de sa puissance et parfois
il ya un malentendu quand on parle de
résilience les gens pensent que la
résilience c'est la réparation parfaite
comme si vous aviez été bon c'est vous
aviez souffert de quelque chose et tout
à coup vous allez maintenant les failles
et tout va bien mais en fait la raison
face à la résilience pas la promesse que
vous allez vous réparez c'est la
promesse que vous allez réussir à vivre
avec ce qui est castré en vous et ça
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
d'apprendre à vivre avec les failles et
les faillites et les manques et les
deuils
c'est ça l'enjeu de l'existence c'est
surtout pas de faire comme si on allait
tout réparer faire comme si ça n'avait
pas eu lieu
d'ailleurs il ya aussi beaucoup du bout
des gants par exemple l'achat beach est
une femme et que vous allez rencontrer à
new york et qui est qui est obsédé par
l'organisation de ses obsèques
et vous dites d'ailleurs dans la région
la mort dont nous appartient pas
d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant
et puis il ya des chapitres
particulièrement peut-être émouvant sur
la perte d'un enfant et là c'est vrai
que le ramma que vous êtes et d'écrivain
l'écrivaine se rejoignent puisque vous
vous rappelez que bon quand on perd un
conjoint en et veufs
mais quand on perd ses parents est
orphelin mais quand on perd un enfant
n'y a pas de nous c'est important ça de
pouvoir nommer aussi oui mais on voit
bien à travers ce manque de langage
c'est pas du tout quoi par exemple
comment appeler quelqu'un qui perd un
enfant n'y a pas de mots en français
dans de très nombreuses langues n'y a
pas de mots pour cette situation en
hébreu ya un mot qui existe d'ailleurs
un mot très poétique et très beau pour
décrire un pour donner une image
métaphore de quelqu'un qui a perdu sa
descendance mais en fait cet homme
cette difficulté à utiliser les mots
face à la mort
raconte quelque chose en fait la mort
c'est ce qui explique pour langage ne
sait parler que de la vie et des vivants
mais dès qu'on parle de la mort dès
qu'on parle aux endeuillés ça nous est
tous arrivé on devient incroyablement
maladroit avec les mots dit des choses
qui sont erronés ou à la droite
on sait pas quoi tenir parce que la mort
des choix entre langage oui alors il ya
elle ça on l'a dit tout à l'heure mark
simmons moïse et les autres alors on les
a tous suivi à travers votre livre et
ses histoires individuelles comme ça par
petites touches
elles prennent elles forment in fine et
un tableau plus global qui là on l'a dit
tout à l'heure à nous interroge sur
notre propre finitude en somme est votre
livre alors c'est vrai qui nous console
même si notre besoin de consolation est
impossible évidemment à rassasier donc
peut-on au fond accepté de laisser une
trace complète dans nos vies et
peut-être deuxième question en même
temps est ce que vous diriez que
judaïsme est quand même un peu moins
rassurant le catholicisme sur la
président c'est pas lé pape assure qu'on
pouvait me considérer qu' il est plus
angoissant d'une certaine manière parce
que la tradition vive n'importe pas une
réponse à l'après vie contrairement à
d'autres traditions religieuses dans le
judaïsme quoi habite est possible et des
spéculations
les gens qui vont vous dire que après la
vie on repose en paix on va au jardin
d'éden
on s'élève vers le créateur on est
réincarné enfin toutes ces possibilités
sont évoquées mais aucune d'entre elles
n'emportent la mise donc il ya un flou
particulier d'ailleurs de façon
intéressante je le raconte dans le livre
le lieu où on va après la mort mais bon
ça s'appelle cheol et ça veut dire la
question
en fait quand on marque on tombe dans la
question il ya des gens qui trouvent ça
très angoissée pasky tu aimerais qu'on
leur dise voilà ce qui va vous arriver
voilà quels sont les certitudes mais en
fait il ya d'autres baisses au cours
s'ils considèrent au contraire il faut
garder cette question ouverte
et quand rien du tout l'enjeu dans la
vie c'est pas d'apprendre à mourir c'est
d'apprendre à vivre la nouvelle
évidemment on peut pas évoquer à toto
les cerros tableaux qui sont absolument
tout ce fourbi table et passionnant mais
c'est vrai que alors votre livre
s'appuie évidemment sur des textes
bibliques mais on sent aussi l'
influence ou d'historiens comme
qui pariait zoug ou de philosophes comme
lyon qui lévite jeu peut-être peut-être
comme roland barthes dans ce combat au
fond qu'est ancestrale entre la
philosophie d'un côté et leur religion
de l'autre on apprécions que finalement
vous ne choisissez pas non parce que je
crois si je crois vraiment moi en
quelque chose c'est à la nécessité de
vivre entre plusieurs mondes je suis
toujours très inquiète et est très
anxieuse quand je rencontre des gens
n'habitent que d'un seul monde le nouvel
aspect ans sous le nom de la poésie me
monte de la religion au moins
l'expérience humaine véritable vous
voyez j'ai entre des univers entre des
langages et moi c'est vrai que j'ai eu
la chance de vivre dans des pays
différents entre des langues différents
de changer de carrière de changer de
visage
j'ai grande gratitude aujourd'hui à
l'égard de tout ce que c'est
voyage entre des mondes m'ont permis
d'être fair ou de banco espagne d'un
solide
j'écris j'ai fait proposer un voyage
tout univers
je me suis quitte pas les uns les autres
et se complètent on avait beaucoup de
questions à vous poser mais le temps sur
le sol est le plus grand luxe
il faut de temps libre sur le taux et la
religion se serait aussi merci
infiniment
delphine horvilleur je rappelle le titre
de ce livre vivre avec nos morts et
c'est chez grasset
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]